[Music]
eh what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here so
ever since that top five phones of 2013
video I've gotten a lot of questions
about this this is the 32 gigabyte white
Nexus 5 which I called
the closest thing to my daily driver and
a lot has actually changed about this
phone since it first came out around two
months ago some software has changed and
actually some hardware - believe it or
not so this is the Nexus 5 revisited now
I'll have my original Nexus 5 review
link tri-polar that like button for
anyone who missed it or just wants to
see it again
but if you remember that video I was
actually a pretty big fan of the
hardware and the choice I made of the
Stormtrooper white or panda design
overlay all matte black Nexus 5 and I'm
so glad I made this decision my biggest
concern with it was not the glossy sides
but actually whether or not it would get
dirty and so far it really hasn't it's
the same bright white as the dad took
out the box it's only been 2 months but
you know it's good to know that it's not
discolouring and I obviously take really
good care of my phones but this one goes
in and out of my pocket all the time and
still looks fresh I also thought that
maybe the white earpiece would become a
focal point if it ever got dirty but
again it's just as clean and subtle as
ever and more and more I've noticed that
the white and black two-tone design
actually kind of makes the phone appear
a little bit thinner overall maybe I'm
just imagining things but essentially
I'm really happy with the design and the
hardware nearly two months after taking
out the box but a few things have also
changed about the Nexus 5 since that day
first of all it's launched with Android
4.4 now it has gotten two software
updates to bring it to Android 4.4.2
kitkat so there's a new software here it
basically makes the biggest change to
the camera so now while the image
quality is just a slightly better with a
little bit better colors and contrast
and a bit more saturation it's mostly
about the shooting speed here so if you
remember the old camera the old camera
took several seconds to switch to HDR
plus mode and take an HDR shot and even
the regular shots you took were a pain
it took a couple of seconds and it was
really difficult to get a confident shot
now opening the camera software and
taking a regular shot is much faster
with the new software with the
in-between shot time basically shrinking
to almost zero again an HDR plus mode
is about as fast as taking regular
photos was before on old software plus
you get the sweet animation to let you
know that you're actually doing work
when you're taking an HDR shot so
basically it really does make sense now
to leave HDR mode on all the time to
take better shots but if you ever just
really need to fire off some quick snaps
the Nexus 5 is finally ready to do that
at a reasonably fast speed so now while
the Nexus 5 might not be the best camera
in any smartphone I mean it's still
definitely not the best at least it's
not a pain to shoot with anymore and
that's a big complaint that a lot of
people including me had when we first
got it now another extremely specific
thing that has changed about the Nexus 5
is the speaker now it turns out there's
a new hardware revision of the Nexus 5
in the Google Play Store that has
slightly bigger speaker grille holes and
the only way to tell if you have the new
one or not is actually to look at a
picture of the old versus the new one
and see which one looks more like yours
but I mean if you've had yours for more
than a week you probably have the old
one but unfortunately from experience it
doesn't really matter from hearing the
old and the new the speakers on this
$350 smartphone just are not good
that hasn't changed you'd be better off
with headphones anyway but other than
that the rest of Android 4.4.2 that
whole KitKat experience is basically as
you would expect clean smooth and
polished as ever
now since this Nexus 5 is the phone I
keep coming back to after testing and
using other phones at least for the past
few months I figured I'd show you guys
basically my default standard home
screens and you can judge them all you
want but it's basically a pretty simple
setup that I have and I like it a lot
I only have three home screens other
than the Google now page and two of them
are completely widgets so the first one
is - clock widget is my default I have a
couple of plugins in here actually to
give me some glanceable information and
I'll have links to all of these things
the important ones below but yeah -
clock is basically the best besides -
clock I have on the second home screen
that today agenda widget my life kind of
relies on Google Tasks and Google
Calendar so that's where my pretty
calendar is always at for me and to the
right of that is my little grid of my
most used apps like daily used apps so
feel free to judge all you want I pretty
much open all of these apps on every
phone I test every day but yeah that's
the set up of course I have a ton more
apps in here if you look in my app
drawer
that's if you want to pause on any of
these screens to get some ideas for
yourself feel free those are all the
apps I have installed which isn't
actually a whole ton but it's what I
feel is necessary and also for those of
you who care yes I have turned on the
arced Android runtime and I'm loving it
and something else that's nice is I've
seen battery life get better on the
Nexus 5 since day one again back in my
initial review I couldn't get the Nexus
5 to last me a full day with the typical
heavy use that I have but strangely the
battery life has consistently gotten
better and better and now it lasts me
through the day almost like I had to
like break in the battery or let it
figure itself out or something plus I
picked up the wireless charger so now
I'm pretty much set not to worry about
this battery anymore so that's the Nexus
5 a few months later even though I carry
it I do still recommend the Moto X to a
lot of Android switchers just because it
fits in people's hands better usually
but just because of all the fixes to
some of the biggest software flaws on
the Nexus 5 mainly the camera and
actually the battery this is solidifying
itself as one of the best smartphone
options out there especially because of
the super low price which you just can't
forget about I carry it often with the
Sony rx100 in the other pocket when I
want to take some actually good photos
or sometimes even with the iPhone or
whatever other phone I am testing and a
lot of the other phones and stuff that I
immediately get are just compared to the
Nexus 5 it's the benchmark so there you
have it thanks for watching and I'll
talk to you guys very soon in the next
one peace